This week on thought those,
we bring it all the boys to the yard,
but the glass Menagerie by Tennessee
Williams,
my main narrator,
tom gives us the low down that
everything we about to people on this
stage is a memory of his dad.
His Dad,
he skipped town a long time ago,
leaving his Mama,
Amanda and her sister Laura cashed out
on the struggle,
so now tom got to be the breadwinner is
grubbing time and wingfield crib where
Amanda like Laura,
keep that as tight to make sure the boys
were highland mama bugging that lower
going to be single forever,
but Lord don't expect any browsers to
show up one to woo her and since she got
a busted ass foot and always acting all
shy and Amanda started running her mouth
about how she was so fine back in the
day that she had 17 busters and one
afternoon trying to get a crack at that
ghetto booty.
Amanda say she could've bagged a rich
playboy,
but she chose that scrub ass daddy.
Instead.
Later Lord making show her glass
collection shines.
When Mama gets all tears saying why you
ain't been going to that school,
I paid for it.
Apparently Laura been ducking out and
walking around birdhouses and Amanda
about had it with you like girl.
Has there ever been a brother you wanted
a piece of that was this fly player
named Jim back in high school who used
to call me blue roses,
but jim was to happen and to kick it
with Laura.
A couple months later,
a man again Tom's grill.
When he snapped and say,
woman,
stop riding my nuts trying to control
me.
I'm the one bringing home the bread tom
piece out to the movies,
but mama say he probably doing something
scandalous,
grabbed the car which and bails.
Next morning Tom Apologizes for being a
dick and said he go to the movies
because he jonesing for a life of
adventure.
Mama say,
boy,
you better get your head out of your
ass.
We got to make plans for Laura Hooker.
Robber one of them warehouse boys you
work with.
So later,
Tom,
tell his momma he got to do name
O'connor dropping by.
Amanda loses trying to prep and Tom say
chill.
He doesn't even know about lower.
I mean real talk.
She crippled and spent all day with her
glass animals.
Next night,
tom started talking about that boy Jim,
who used to have the hots for dude was
bawling.
Man.
He had mad whose skills was the
president of every damn club and can
even drive some ill rhymes.
Bang.
Show them changed because now he
grinding away at the same broke ass job
as time a man.
That stuff's lower.
Brossa them titties looking fine.
Then she dropped the big news that cat
dropping by his Jim Laura wigs out so
hard that when the boys arrived,
Loyola Chokes and got a dip out to
another room.
Damn Law Jim and Tom to compensate by
the White House apparently about the get
the poop,
but he already got plans to join the
merchant.
Siemens young.
Matter of fact,
he signed up using a chat if he was
opposed to pay the electric bill with
Amanda buses in Jabber and again about
how all the brothers wanted her back
then and it's all sipping and child with
till Bam.
The lights go out,
he's bought some candles and a man to
tell Jim to pull up a glass of wine for
Loehr.
Jim stopped throwing game that Laura
calling her old fashioned type of girl
and said he never noticed her Janki legs
back in high school.
Laura talking about school and her glass
collection.
When Jill said,
girl,
you so fly,
you don't even know it.
You just need some confidence.
Boom,
the Laura show him her favorite thing,
a glass Unicorn.
Jim,
here's somebody dropping some fresh
beets nearby.
So we ask Lord a dance.
They bring it on the dance floor.
When crash,
that Unicorn gets busted,
rather beg,
and he got to build her confidence.
So he kissed her,
but then immediately recognizes he dumb
dumb because turns out he getting
married next month.
Damn Laura gives him the broken unicorn
as a souvenir.
Ge thinks when a man that comes in,
just say,
Yo gotta bounce.
I'm engaged.
Thanks for the dinner and Unicorn
though,
Amanda just about ourselves and starts
getting crunk on time.
Say He made them look like fools.
Bring her home and engaged.
Man.
He ain't nothing but a selfish asshole
who's head is always in the cloud.
Thompson's doses out of that trap to get
his adventure on,
but no matter how far you go,
you always thinking of his post system.
There's a play as a choice example of
what my boys,
he will cause plastic bed and then the
pet gang.
Everything on stage,
I'm talking props,
sounds,
music,
lighting,
wrapping the phase that's gone on inside
the character's domes and then the glass
menagerie.
All that mess is showing how the feel
family's dreams ain't jiving with
reality.
Remember,
this crew got some fantasy world that
they live in La,
spend her days chilling with her glass
Menagerie,
creating a place where she ain't got to
deal with all of them real life.
Ask Her mom,
always dogging her,
not being shy,
bugging out at school.
I could go on and play up at Williams
getting on his plastic theater jam.
Describe the reality of Laura's
situation by comparing her to that
glass.
Just peaked the stage direction.
Be a fragile unearthly.
Prettiness has come out and Laura,
she is like a piece of translucent
glass.
Touch by light,
given a momentary radiant,
not actionable,
mad last,
but that glass collection ain't the only
thing.
Wrapping Laura,
Laura recall blue roses because she is a
blue rose.
She mad sensitive,
always feeling blue and got a unique
kind of beauty that you don't usually
find in the hood that busy Amanda always
living in the past when she was a sexy
southern Belle who could get any brother
with just one work.
Now she a single mom who got burned by
some little bitch and is now living a
bleak ass life.
That disparity between life in her mind
and life on a real,
making her act like a damn fool like
when her ugly ass was wearing a dress
made for some young hoochies Tom Dream
about writing and living an adventurous
lifestyle since grinding at the
warehouses Halloween boy talk smack to
his mama and even boost cash from the
family just to add flavor to his own
game even though he peaced out to live
the high life.
Surprise.
Sometimes your dreams get on by reality.
Boys do to become just as bunk as his
pads.
I was pursued by something all at once.
My sister touches my shoulder.
I turn around and look into her eyes.
Oh,
Laura,
Laura.
I tried to leave you behind me,
but I am more faithful than I intended
to be.
Jim was top dog in high school,
but now he had low level scrub busting
his ass at a warehouse,
but even he living in a world of Bush
saying he taken public speaking courses
that's going to shoot him to the top boy
please.
The only way these cats can escape the
prison of their real lives is the lot of
themselves over and over until it sticks
t we'll slang and repetition all up in
his tax.
To make that point,
Amanda always talking about some flower
called John quills to bring her back to
the good old days of attendance and rich
on dogs.
Our so lovely that country and may
literally flooded with John quills.
That was the summer I had the craze for
John Quinones.
John quinones became an absolute
obsession.
Mother said,
honey,
there's no more room for John Quills,
and I still kept on bringing in more
John quills whenever,
wherever I saw him,
I said,
stop,
stop.
I said,
John Quilts.
I made.
The young men helped me gather the John
quills.
It was a joke.
Amanda,
her,
John Quills.
Finally,
there were no more advisors to hold
them.
Every available space was filled with
John quills town.
Keep dropping the words movies and move
the shelly itching to escape this type
of flow as a special kind of repetition
called Politiken when you repeat,
whereas they got the same routes.
Yes,
movies.
Look at them.
You know what happens?
People go to the movies instead of
moving.
I'm tired of the movies and I am about
to move.
Man.
This show do suck a fat one.
When you recognize that your life ain't
going to never be the fantasy in your
head.
The hard truth is that for the Amandas
Toms and lawyers of the world,
sometimes there ain't nothing better you
can do than pull to the side and escape
the cloud.
Nah,
Yo,
thanks for keeping it 100 with me.
Catch on that top one more thing before
you go,
because we've got big news and Shit.
We've launched an audio series.
Thought notes get lit,
and each episode I dive into the list of
the trill is riders,
characters,
plots,
themes,
and more.
All from the world of literature.
So if you like what your boy dot suite
does here with thug notes,
check out those get lit.
It's available on itunes and all these
spots you find podcast.
And as always we've got lots more videos
on the way.
So click here to go to our channel page
and if you haven't already,
make sure to subscribe while you're
there.
Get your star players base.